bonsoir messieurs merci d'être on dirait
que ce soit avec nous sur rt france
younès belle fait là abdelaziz
bouteflika a eu droit à un - bonheur que
ses prédécesseurs pour quelle raison on
évoque un embarras officiel ce que vous
partagez ce point de vue
bonsoir ben je crois que le bilan on va
dire mitigé de
bouteflika il était la vraie raison de
ce qui se passe actuellement c'est à
dire un silence on va dire officiel sort
de l'institution militaire en algérie ou
bien de l'institution présidentielle
mais certainement le monsieur avec un
qu'avec une carrière politique quand
même qu'il était très professionnelle
dans la carrière d'un diplomate
réconciliateur à certains moments de
l'algérie surtout avec avec les
islamistes et
principalement les 20 ans de gouvernance
qui hantait marquer clairement par une
certaine stabilité politique une
certaine ouverture vers des partis de
l'opposition mais surtout des des
conflits
implicite avec avec l'institution un
militaire et surtout principalement dans
la troisième il est en 3e et 4e mandat
présidentiel là où le conflit il était
clairement avec certains certains
généraux maintenant ce qui s'était passé
c'est que l'institution militaire a
saisi l'occasion de 2019 des
contestations à une mobilisation
populaire pour faire défection bien sûr
à tous ce régime de bouteflika mais la
question qui se pose est ce que
effectivement les mots des demandes de
la mobilisation populaire étaient
réalisés je crois pas parce que
jusqu'aujourd'hui est toujours le
mouvement ira qui continuent à demander
la séparation de pouvoirs entre
l'institution militaire et l'institution
on va dire politique et surtout la
diversification de l'économie algérien
qui reste toujours dépendante des
hydrocarbures
on va revenir sur ces points le bilan
d'abdelaziz bouteflika le mouvement du
irak au 6 mai dernier petit ami je
voudrais avoir votre regard sur la
cérémonie d'aujourd'hui ce que les
autorités politiques algériennes ont
raison de faire le strict minimum après
la disparition d'abdelaziz bouteflika
qu'est ce qu'elle redoute
bottleneck heures on pourrait dire oui
mais c'est la formule oui mais oui parce
que c'est un chef historique et est
membre du groupe de ouidah qui est
dirigée par le colonel argoud medica a
pris le pouvoir en 1962 avec arme et
d'un bel ou puis avec le coup d'état du
19 juin 1965
le clan d'oujda a pris tous les pouvoirs
boutaflika était ministre des affaires
étrangères à l'âge de 25 ans imaginons à
25 ans évidemment il était commandant de
l'armée de libération nationale
algérienne de la laine donc c'est un mot
j'ai donc c'est un mot j'ai ce qu'il a
fait après il a été éloigné de pouvoir
en
1978 par le colonel kasdi merbah surtout
le patron puissant de la sécurité
militaire à l'époque et l'a utilisé son
veto contre bouteflika le bras droit
d'aubry dié puis de traverser le désert
entre abou dhabi à genève sur toi genève
il a vécu à genève il a fréquenté les
librairies à genève il aime beaucoup
lire donc et c'est bien story ainsi
pendant la traversée de désert il a été
sollicité par l'armée en
1994 d'être le président il a refusé
pendant la guerre civile mais en 1999 il
a accepté il a accepté ses oeuvres à
l'intérieur de l'algérie évidemment
c'est la réconciliation nationale et la
mique fin à la guerre civile
mais en même temps aussi hélas rayonner
encore de nouveaux l'algérie sur la
scène régionale et internationale
or parce que pendant la décennie noire
en algérie a été très affaibli sur la
scène internationale il a eu beaucoup de
chance au plan économique puisque le
baril de pétrole atteint même 150
dollars par baril donc l'état algérien
se trouvait avec lui avec plus de 200
milliards de dollars dans des trésors
donc hélas il a bien fait bourse sa
faute très grave évidemment c'est qu'il
a modifié la constitution pour le
troisième mandat ça veut dire au lieu de
se retirer après deux mandats lui même
déjà il a un discours il a dit notre
génération a fait son devoir va se
retirer gilles la tare originelle les
algériennes vont comprendre de ce que
j'ai dis donc mais il n'a pas tenu
promesse il a modifié la caution pas en
troisième fois en 2013 il à elle à une
attaque cérébrale dont il a passé la
plupart du temps jusqu'à 10 jusqu'à 2019
avec nous dans les hôpitaux au début
c'est gaël 22 grèce s'enfonce puis une
fine pointe et génère parce qu'il aime
beaucoup la ville de genève mais il n'a
pas compris le moment historique parce
qu'un certain moment donné il faut se
retirer si le même problème avec
bourguiba en tunisie où d'autres chefs
arabes malheureusement ils ont fait nos
devoirs historique ils ont donné
beaucoup et beaucoup mais n'ont pas
compris que la présidence à vie nous
sommes dans des républiques ne sont pas
dans des des monarchies donc depuis
l'aggravation de sa santé aux mines 2013
c'est son temps réel un clan mafieux
dirigé par son frère saïd bouteflika qui
est actuellement présent la même chose
son mini premier ministre ahmed ouyahia
qui est toujours aussi actuellement en
prison et à dominique celle ci
soulignait elle est adepte de patron des
patrons mari dean tarkos les la famille
reconnue neuf sont tous en prison
aujourd'hui après le havre ac de 2019
donc c'est pour cela on a toujours la
formule vis-à-vis de bouteflika oui mais
est aussi l'ami intellectuels écrivains
personnellement il m'a envoyé une lettre
en 2014 en 2004 en soutenant mon corps à
jour mes travaux sur l'algérie aux
particuliers sur le monde arabe en
général donc sit-in personnalité aussi
populaire charismatique il jouit d'un
charisme et cinq grands orateurs ce soit
en arabe ou en français mais
malheureusement et la rate et l'histoire
ont modifié la constitution pour avoir
troisième mandat et ses détracteurs
évoquent aussi ce népotisme 7
corruption
il y aune slc là est ce que vous direz
qu'il ya un paradoxe avec ce qu'il a
incarné au début de sa vie politique
après l'indépendance de l'algérie
moi je crois qu'il a bien profité de ses
deux premiers mandats parce que il faut
rappeler à l'époque c'est pour ça que
j'étais que l'algérie est toujours
dépendante des hydrocarbures le prix des
hydrocarbures on était entre 100 et 150
dans la houle pour le baril donc ce qui
fait que toute cette manne financière a
été exploitée pour certains projets de
l'infrastructure mais surtout aussi pour
acheter la paix sociale en sera fait
dire que l'algérie était parmi les
premiers pays dans ce qu'on a appelé
médiatiquement le printemps arabe en
2011 il y avait des manifestations et
rapidement là la réaction de bouteflika
et de son équipe était le fait de
mobiliser ce qu'on peut appeler
l'économie de rente pour
calmer aller de mon des manifestations
maintenant ça n'a pas marché bien sûr en
2010 la peintre deux raisons parce que
d'abord le cri de pétrole n'est plus à
100 à 150 dollars pour le pour le baril
toujours l'algérie bien sûr dépendante
des hydrocarbures quatre-vingt dix pour
cent des exportations algériens sont
principalement le pétrole et le gaz mais
surtout aussi le conflit avec
l'institution militaire parce qu'il a
fait chuter quand même certains généraux
comme tueur fuir comme papa comme des
conflits bien sûr avec avec d'autres
généraux aussi entre 2015 jusqu'en 2019
et bien sûr y avait aussi l'homme fort m
gates alors qu'ils voulaient profiter de
cette situation pour prendre le pouvoir
maintenant le paradoxe est ce que
j'arrive pas à comprendre c'est cette
situation de de ceux qui dirigent
l'algérie actuellement c'est-à-dire
images issues principalement qui a
travaillé en tant que ministre de
l'habitat avec avec bouteflika et après
premier ministre si dans le gouvernement
algérien et jusqu'aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de réaction par contre je comprends
parfaitement la réaction du président
macron parce qu à l époque où tous les
cas la france devenue le deuxième
partenaire commercial de l'algérie après
la chine ya 450 entreprises françaises
qui exploite le marché algérien
principalement dans les hydrocarbures le
pharmaceutique l'alimentaire est
également le secteur financier et
bancaire et ce sont aussi des échanges
commerciaux qui qui sont bien sûr
positif très très positif pour pour la
france
emmanuel macron que vous citez un
instant qui est donc qualifié abdelaziz
bouteflika de figures majeures de
l'algérie contemporaine et de
partenaires exigent pour la france
durant ces vingt années au pouvoir rien
de sita oui le mouvement citoyen du irak
c'est lui qui est à l'origine de la
démission d'abdelaziz bouteflika est ce
qui vous ce que vous direz qu'il a porté
ses fruits
oui évidemment parce que le slogan
principal de r accès pas de cinquième
mandat foot africain en fait la crise
algérienne sont conscients ils ont visé
plus l'entourage de bouteflika l art à
leur tête sans fins aïn touta finira que
vote affirme lui-même boutaflika les ans
il était handicapée et l'été elle était
et il a passé la plupart du temps dans
les hôpitaux plus que la compagnie de
mort a dit est donc vraiment depuis 2000
13 foot africain n'a pas gouverné et lui
même n'est pas corrompu il faut savoir
lui même n'est pas corrompu n'a pas soif
et d'accumuler de free qui n'a pas des
fortunes en suisse mais et l'a encouragé
ou là ou là là c'est cher les corrompus
nous l'a laissé faire la correction est
il satisfait méthode avec des dés des
chefs arabes autoritaires qu'ils sont
eux mêmes sont pas corrompus mais qu'ils
laissent sur leur entourage tomber dans
la correction pourquoi parce qu'après
c'est facile à aller faire chanter c'est
facile à gouverner et tard il devient et
deviennent très au buisson vis-à-vis du
chef de l'état ça c'est une stratégie
malheureusement paix n'est pas payant à
nanterre et ceux qui passaient le ra que
j'ai bien suivi parce que à la fin dès
lors à la fin de mois d'avril 2002
heures j'ai publié mon livre en langue
arabe la fin du règne de bouteflika
parce que je savais pas je savais bien
que connaissant les algériens qui ne
vont pas accepter un cinquième mandat il
veut pas être dirigée par ce qu'ils
appellent le cadre les cadres parce que
dans les meetings où on dit sous la
tutelle de présente boutaflika il
mettait à gagner derrière le micro c'est
pas le cadre de potash rica c'est pas le
portrait de bouteflika qui pourrait
gouverner donc son entourage qui sont
actuellement
les ont aidés et à leur tête son frère
saïd bouteflika et son premier ministre
ahmed ouyahia et les grands
milliardaires algériens sont depuis 2002
neuf jusqu'à nos jours en prison et
encore pour des dizaines d'années la c1
qui ont gravé la situation c'est un qui
sont responsables de la corruption mais
un président gravement malade qui est
d'or qui passe tout son temps dans les
hôpitaux qui paralysait complètement on
ne peut pas l'accuser de corruption de
l'enrichissement lui il était d'andorre
du tableau politique malheureusement
c'est son entourage qui a profité de son
image qui a ensuite profité de son
capital symbolique et à profiter de sa
popularité
afin d'accélérer la corruption éditeurs
et profits sous le règne de bouteflika
mais pour ta venue car physiquement même
je parle l'était pas responsable de
cette vague de correction un dernier mot
avec vous et younes belle fait là c'est
ce que réclamait le mouvement du irak
que se tourne la page de l'ère
bouteflika est ce qu avec sa disparition
c'est effectivement une passe d'une page
de l'histoire algérienne qui se tourne
bel et bien aux finalement les choses
n'ont pas réellement chaud maintenant
moi je suis pas d'accord par le fait de
dire que le ra qu'il était seulement
contre contre bouteflika ou contrôler le
cinquième mandat non le harry continue
jusqu'aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'il est
contre toute la trajectoire de
l'histoire de l'algérie après
l'indépendance c'est à dire le fait que
le pays est gouverné par une junte
militaire qui détient tout le pouvoir
sécuritaire politique économique et
surtout le pouvoir aussi un financier et
commercial de ce pays donc il faut
rappeler que sous tous les responsables
actuellement soit dans le gouvernement
bien dans l'institution militaire ils
ont travaillé avec l'ère bush à flers a
certainement y avait de la corruption
les rapports internationaux parlent de
2000 milliards de dollars qui a été volé
pendant les 20 dernières haies les 20
dernières années mais aussi je crois que
le ra contenu et qui avoue une malle
compréhension parce qu'ils dirigent
l'algérie actuellement parce qu'ils
avaient pas comprendre qu'il y ait une
nouvelle génération d'abord
démographique de la population
algérienne une nouvelle génération de
problématiques qui est lié
principalement à la diversification et
économique l'ouverture politique tout en
gardant bien évidemment la stabilité du
pays et ce sera le mot de la fin merci à
tous les deux d'avoir participé à cet
échange ce soir une asbl fait la
consultant en relations internationales
riadh sidaoui directeur du centre arabe
de recherche et d'analysé politique et
social de genève les recettes les deux
et à bientôt sur rt france